calculemos 10.1 menos 393 y te invito a
que le des pausa al vídeo e intentes
hacerlo por tu cuenta después podrás ver
si lo hicimos de la misma manera que
escribamos la operación de manera
vertical alineando el punto decimal y
las posiciones de los números el 3 está
en la posición de las unidades justo
debajo del cero 3.93 ahí la tenemos
hagamos el cálculo antes de hacer la
resta queremos que todos los números que
están arriba sean mayores a los que
están abajo de hecho aquí no tenemos un
número pero podemos poner un cero déjame
ponerlo con otro color
ponemos el 0 10.1 es lo mismo que 10.10
pero también tenemos el siguiente
problema 0 es menor que 31 es menor que
90 es menor que 3 vamos a tener que
reagrupar los números
esta escena que tenemos aquí la quitamos
de las decenas dejamos en cero las
decenas y la pasamos como 10 unidades
una decena son 10 unidades de estas 10
unidades
tomamos una nos quedan entonces 9 y la
que tomamos lo usamos como 10 décimas
así es que nos quedarían aquí 10 décimas
más una once décimas finalmente de estas
once décimas agarramos una nos van a
quedar diez décimas y la que tomamos se
hace diez centésimas más cero nos quedan
diez centésimas y ahora ya podemos hacer
la resta pues las cifras que tenemos
arriba son mayores o por lo menos
iguales a las que tenemos abajo así que
10 menos 3 7 10 menos 9 es 1 el punto
decimal lo bajamos 9 menos 36 este cero
no cuenta en realidad y obtenemos que
10.1 menos 3.93 es 6.17 ese es el
resultado de nuestra resta